La vidéo a tourné sur les réseaux sociaux.
On y voit une jeune femme ici en orange invectiver
violemment deux autres femmes d'origine africaine
et voilées. On ne connaît pas l'origine
de l'altercation mais à l'encontre des deux
personnes assises sur la banquette un flot
d'injures à caractère raciste.
Dans un premier temps les deux femmes visées
se contiennent et sourient même de la situation,
mais au bout d'une petite minute le ton monte
d'un cran.
Lorsque soudain, la violence remplace les
mots.
Les passagers s'interposent alors difficilement
entre les jeunes femmes et tentent de les
calmer. La voyageuse est invitée à sortir
du tram, mais elle refuse et joue encore la
provocation.
Fin des violences, restent de nouvelles insultes
racistes.
La scène a eu lieu dimanche dernier à 18H15
à hauteur de l'avenue de Grammont, entre
les stations Liberté et Suzanne Valadon.
Avertie par le chauffeur, la police n'a pu
retrouver sur place aucun des protagonistes.
Elle n'a reçu à ce jour aucune plainte mais
a ouvert une enquête. Les images des caméras
ont été visionnées pour tenter d'identifier
l'auteure de l'agression, une femme qui encourt
jusqu'à 6 mois de prison et 22 000 € d'amende
pour injures à caractère racial.